difficile pour le moment d'être sûr de
l'impact du coït sur le marché de
l'immobilier
si on devait résumer ça en une phrase
degré la pierre reste toujours la pierre
est une valeur sûre d'investissement le
continent a bien évidemment mis à
l'arrêt ce secteur comme beaucoup
d'autres près de 270 milles transaction
n'aurait pas habiter sur cette période
ont pourtant les chiffres de prévisions
sur 2020 sont finalement assez proches
de ceux de 2019 année record avec un
million de transactions cette année
pourrait tourner autour des 920 ming
transaction second meilleuragents.com
pour ce qui est des prix ça reste
globalement stable voire souvent en
augmentation même si depuis mars et une
petite mais nette baisse des prix qui
est observé dans certaines grandes
villes environ 0 5% en moins à parier
toulouse ou encore montpellier
pas vraiment étonnant quand on sait
qu'un français sur cinq a mal vécu son
logement lors du confinement
forcément ça donne envie de quitter son
studio de 10 mètres carrés pour une
maison à la campagne
même si ghetto reste toujours très bas
la crise rend les banques plus brunante
avec plus de réticence à accorder des
crédits aux plus fragiles notamment ceux
sans apport ou dont le taux d'effort qui
est le rapport entre les dépenses liées
au logement et les revenus globaux est
trop élevé
[Musique]